joe manchin essentially just ended
joe biden's giant dreams but here's the
thing
that may save joe biden in the long run
because if joe biden actually got built
back better and inflation continued to
spiral out of control and the economy
continued to stagnate
it just would not rebound to ubin's
benefit now i feel i still think that
the democrats get shellacked in 2022
because they're going to have to own
whatever comes next and nothing great is
happening for the next year or so
inflation is going to last well into
next year at this point that is being
conceded by the federal reserve
the economy is not growing the way it is
supposed to grow the democrats have
created a box of their own making they
cannot get out of it with regard to
covet the coveted panic mentality that
they relied upon for world breaking
change has actually broken their world
but
adding on top of that a five trillion
dollar package would not have redounded
to joe biden's benefit so manchin
killing it might counter-intuitively be
actually quite good for joe biden see it
took bill clinton the 1994 election
before he realized that hillary care and
giant capital gains tax increases that
these things were very unpopular with
the american people the way the american
people sounded off was by giving
republicans their first congressional
majority in three decades
well joe biden
he's getting the wake-up call early but
he's not getting it from a congressional
election he's getting it from a member
of his own party in the form of joe
manchin
nonetheless the democrats are really
really angry over all of this naturally
as you would expect them to be because
again the idea was that now that joe
biden was was in control they were going
to get the bernie sanders presidency
they were gonna get exactly what they
had always wanted well no
no that that's not going to happen
anymore so bernie sanders is now
slamming joe manchin here is the
socialist old coot from vermont who's
now the thought leader of the democratic
party who's been defeated by as it turns
out a majority of the american
population let's not pretend that it's
joe manchin and kirsten cinema alone or
standing against this bill because it's
not true 52 senators stand against this
bill a majority of the senate is not a
matter of minority controlling is a
matter of a majority controlling
here's bernie sanders though who is
lamenting this as a as he
as he thinks fondly of stalin
i think he's gonna have a lot of
explaining to do to the people of west
virginia
to tell them why he doesn't have the
guts to take on the drug companies and
lower the cost of prescription drugs
why he is not prepared to expand home
health care west virginia is one of the
poorest states in this country you got
elderly people and disabling disabled
people who would like to stay at home
were forced into nursing homes he's
going to have to tell the people of west
virginia why he doesn't want to expand
medicare to cover dental hearing and
eyeglasses i i've been to west virginia
a number of times and it's a great state
beautiful people but it is a state that
is struggling
okay so i would just like to point out
here that bernie sanders would not be
elected dog catcher in west virginia so
bernie sanders giving
advice to joe manchin who's been elected
as a blue senator in a very red state
repeatedly is laughable
if if bernie sanders believes that his
agenda is so popular why wasn't he the
nominee in the first place and again i
will never get over the fact that joe
biden is such a fool that he was elected
as a moderate and then he swung to the
bernie sanders side of the aisle it's
totally crazy to me okay alexander
ocasio-cortez is also jumping into the
fray so she tweeted out when a handful
of us in the house warned this would
happen if democratic leaders gave
manchin everything he wanted first by
moving the infrastructure plan before
buildback better instead of passing it
together many ridiculed our position
maybe they'll believe us next time or
maybe people will just keep calling us
naive
either way we cannot accept no for an
answer democratic leadership including
but not limited to the president himself
and house democratic leadership wrote a
massive check on their credibility the
night of the biff vote in order to
secure the votes they needed promising
passage of buildback better to every
member who brought up mansion they
personally promised they had a solution
and bill back better would pass it is
simply not an option for democratic
leaders to walk away from buildback
batter voting rights etc they must find
a way just as they promised they would
when we raise this inevitability some of
us don't have the luxury of giving up we
serve working middle class and poor
people we serve everyday workers getting
ripped off and immigrants and black
communities and queer kids needing
shelter we will not walk away from them
and leadership can't walk away from them
either people can be mad at mansion all
they want but we knew he would do this
months ago where we need answers are
from are the leaders who promised a path
on buildback better if biff passed biden
and democratic leaders they chose to
move biff alone instead of with bill
back better not mansion so they need to
fix it
we as always says aoc are here to fight
for this agenda what matters most to us
is that it gets done but we cannot just
shrug our shoulders and accept this as
some charlie brown moment our entire
democracy is on the line so we need to
get back in there and get this bleep
done period
so
slay queen yeah go for it seriously go
for it the entire progressive wing of
the party is super mad that they even
got built the the infrastructure plan so
it seems that aoc is still committed to
the idea that if the progressives had
voted no on infrastructure and they had
held together billback better and
infrastructure that mansion would have
voted for that
no he wouldn't dove literally the only
thing that joe manchin would have voted
for is the infrastructure plan he was
not going to vote for both the only way
possibly he might have voted for both is
if republicans were the ones obstructing
the inf obstructing the infrastructure
plan right that was the romney logic
but
they weren't joe manchin was not going
to vote for a seven trillion dollar
package because aoc and illinois wanted
it these people are out of their minds
they they truly do seem to think that
like small boroughs in new york govern
the entire country
and that senators are not answerable to
their home states
and illinois joined the crew she slammed
mansion as well here is the
horrible congresswoman from minnesota
we all knew that uh sander mansion
couldn't be trusted um you know the the
excuses that he just made um i think are
complete
um it is really disheartening uh to hear
him say that he has been trying to get
there for the people of west virginia um
because that's a complete lie there are
just so many things that you know the
people of west virginia desperately need
and we know that he is not
working on
behalf of their interest and i really am
just completely disappointed and
disgusted by his reasoning
well i mean
if the people of west virginia don't
love ilha omar i mean wow i mean when
she speaks the people of west virginia
listen that is definitely a state west
virginia where ilhan omar i'm sure is
wildly popular her perspectives are
super popular in west virginia again the
delusional nature of progressives who
think they have a national program as
opposed to the reality of politics which
is you're always cobbling together a
coalition to do incremental things that
is most of politics and that it turns
out joe biden did not have a mandate for
anything remotely like this
it's amazing and they will continue
deluding themselves along these lines
the progressives which means that joe
biden should get with the program right
if he had any brains at all if he didn't
have mush for brains at this point which
i mean physically much for brains then
he would probably be pushing for a
piecemeal approach to a lot of this
legislation but i don't know if he can
do it i don't know if joe biden can get
there he's so afraid of the progressive
wing because they're the most motivated
wing even though they represent a tiny
percentage of his party that he's going
to continue pushing this it's utterly
insane
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit that subscribe button so you stay up
to date with all our future content